so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna tie
this up in a bow if you're feeling that
okay this is stuff I need to keep on
working on for my assessments right
thankfully you have like more work than
you can shake a stick at it's already
been a sign it's already on canvas let
me walk you quickly through pot day
potty we're not gonna do I'm just going
to show it to you okay so potty
let's deal with the tangent then we'll
deal with the normal so when I want a
tangent like this okay I know two things
about it number one I know the points
that it goes through
well at least I'm about to find it out
and I also know how steep or shallow it
is
I know it's gradient so when you've got
a straight line you've got a point
you've got a gradient which form of a
greater in a straight line should I use
pre-created thank you it's got exactly
the information that I'm going to have
access to so this is kind of my target
this is where I'm gonna go okay but of
course the issue is I don't have all
those pieces just yet I've only got one
of them actually I've only got that guy
the x value it's two so to get the other
pieces my y1 and my M I've got to go to
two different places okay to get from
the x value to the corresponding Y value
I'm gonna substitute x equals two into
something on the board what am I gonna
substitute into remember I'm searching
for a Y right maybe I should go to F X
because that's equal to Y remember that
it literally says y equals a thing right
so if I put two into here I get 8 minus
4 which is 4 so that's what's gonna go
in there okay
now the other thing I'm searching for is
M that's a gradient what's the thing
I've worked out that helps me determine
gradient the derivative thank you it's
right there okay so I'm going to take
the same x equals two and I'm going to
pop it in 3 times 4 is 12 take away 4 is
8 so that what there it is that's my
gradient okay now I'm just going to take
that and I'm gonna tidy it up to get
this and then you can simplify that a
little bit further that will be the
tangent okay now they're normal
take that same process and it changes it
just one teeny little bit can you just
um pause writing for a second and I want
you to look at this right same x-value
same y value but the normals
perpendicular so I don't want this eight
I don't that's not the gradient what
should the gradient be it'll be minus
one over eight it's the negative
reciprocal okay now if you can't
remember that this is back in stage 5
when we're learning about straight lines
see how you multiply those together you
get negative one that's what that's what
perpendicular lines are about okay so
when you pop that in you'll get a
different equation and off you go
now the bill is gonna get very shortly
so here's what I'm going to suggest in a
second you can take a picture of this
watch take a pictures of all now go
ahead and do it but then I'm going to
pull up and des also I want to show you
a summary of everything without doing
any of your working okay
so Tyler tomorrow got it then okay here
we go if you didn't get it someone's
gonna have to send it to you
okay sorry Sarang so I'm left to send to
you all right have a look please um mrs.
Lee's could we get the lights please
thank you all right what are we looking
at sorry I'm just gonna do this no
that's fine okay you eleven stay with me
H thanks for showing good on you all
right this is our original function f of
X equals that guy it's the cubic that
you guys all helped me work out earlier
starting to make sure yep some projector
mode now the blue and the green point
the blue and the green point remember
what they were what we call them again
names stationery weights turning points
and that's where they are exactly bang
on where it happens okay now the next
thing we said was what if we compare
that to f of X minus 2 f of X minus 2
here is what f of X minus 2 looks like
there it is you can see it's moved over
everything's moved over two units right
which is exactly what we predicted okay
now what we then said was can we work
out these tangents and normals okay now
from memory I think it was what Y minus
four equals eight outside of what was it
X minus two thank you so X minus two
okay now I've got to zoom a little bit
whoops there we go what do you reckon
guys think it's pretty much bang on okay
there's the tangent there's no
intersects and of course if I take that
same thing Y minus four and I say equals
the set of eight what did I say I should
do for the normal negative whatever
right thank you so negative one over
eight and then I'm going to put in the
same X minus two that I had earlier and
when you have a look at this it doesn't
look like it's at right angles right but
the reason why is because of how I
zoomed so let me just fix that there we
go there I am at right angles you can
see when I've got the scale right
there's the black one there's the red
one there's the ninety degrees okay
now the final question which we have not
touched at all which is at the bottom of
of that list there is what happens if I
don't do don't move
F of not X not X minus two but minus X
now just before I hit equals there I
just wonder what you predict is going to
happen are you ready there it is okay
it's the horizontal reflection you're 11
good luck in your a peas